allô allô seyfried dont la page se
libére enregistré bon j'en ai capturer
un c'est pas toi
de quoi un cyber historiens weathers
agents
figure toi que son ancêtre c'est le
barman de là où je squatte est l'année
du coup il a essayé de me coincer à la
sortie en se faisant passer pour lui et
je suis le premier abord bref en tout
cas j'ai commencé le travail gentiment
et six jeux plus d'infos non non non non
non tu nous attend parce que on est une
équipe
bon oui et vous alors j'en ai marre de
entendu gémir là je t'envoie l'adresse
pourquoi comment ça tu envoies l'adresse
d'envoi un pigeon voyageur
[Musique]
c'était vraiment pas facile à trouver
ton entre 1000 et où l'agent plus
chaudes fait juste attaquer un peu les
ongles c'est moi l'agent sauvez-moi de
cette folle alors écoute moi la journée
est super histoire j'ai rien contre toi
mais apparemment tu veut notre peau à
moi et à ma descendante alcoolique et
abondance être relou alors tu vas me
dire tout ce que tu sais maintenant j'ai
pas l'habitude de torture et les gens
mais j'ai lu tout ce qu'il faut savoir
sur les ans thalie depuis que je suis
ici et je n'hésiterai pas à m'en servir
tu vas parler aux stocks d'hosties
jusqu'à ce que 300 par les bourses
aliénor ils sont mais moi de cette toile
relève toi aliénor les ans un peu pour
les autres c'est pas juste
tu as déjà commencé fait quoi alors on
lui met une barre de fer rougi dans les
mains si nous avions un aigle on
pourrait lui faire tes sourires fois
j'ai que ça dans un vieux livre
moi je dis on lui arrache une extrémité
juste estime non mais je veux bien
parler en fait j'en peu douillet donc si
on pouvait éviter tout ce que vous venez
de dire ça m'arrangerait ok ok d'abord
je fait qu'obéir aux ordres et si on m'a
dit de venir vous tuer ses passions que
vous êtes des anachronismes qui est ce
que tu traites d'anachronismes marins
d'eau douce
ce n'est pas une insulte pour votre
information peut continuer bref s'il ya
quelqu'un qui peut vous grâce et c'est
votre cyber historienne mêlée au 23ème
siècle est pas parfait qu'on dit noël
attend un peu quoi si c'est un piège
m'en fous on fonce mais non c'est pas ça
pourquoi notre cyber historienne
voudrait nous tuer alors que si elle le
fait on meurt
et tu a fallu combien de temps pour
penser à ça non mais je veux dire j'ai
pas d'enfant mois alors si je meurs j'ai
pas de descendance astree n'existe pas
la preuve non plus et la cyber
historienne non plus tu avais pas pensé
à l'agent mais on sait tout ça mais
quand on a valu dans le temps ça a créé
une sorte de paradoxe c'est compliqué en
gros si on revient pas à notre époque un
double parallèle apparaîtra et prendre
notre place tu peux va comprendre
vim c'est dégueulasse
bref tu nous emmènes au 23ème siècle ou
par la patronne rôles chez nous vérité
divine chine c'est quoi ce bordel
ne dites pas que vous avez tué quelqu'un
moscou et comment nous as tu trouvé je
faisais géolocalisés mais bordel c'est
pas faux tout ça je veux rentrer
m'expliquer ce qui se passe et si je
peux vous aider je le fais dans le calme
[Musique]
et